[Music]
welcome to the best day of the year
welcome to day 3 of next this is it this
is my favorite part this is the
developer keynote excited guests on
developers in the room alright we're
gonna have a lot of fun today a lot of
code a lot of demos but I thought I'd
start let's get to know each other sound
good
so uh like let's go show of hands let's
really do this who's a developer in the
room raise your hand if you're a
developer all right how about operators
we love our operators to get some
operators in the room how about some
language stuff any job of developers
yeah I got a lot of Java developers
nodejs Wow a lot of nods yes um go first
go go first love them some go okay
policy ah let's see where you work
who's with an enterprise big company
yeah well done startups okay this is
important is anyone looking for a job
this this guy right here okay talk to
all those people around you they're
hiring so you're all I'll get you set up
look it's a great time to be a developer
like every industry is changing right
software is right in the middle of a lot
of those changes and and you you the
developers you're right in the heart of
it you're driving all that and think
about the tools that you use the tools
that we use are changing everyday also
open source has been just a huge part of
that transformation think about it
when's the last time you actually set up
a server right that's an API call now
how about a configure to configure an
operating system image you don't do that
right that's all containers it's all
just a library of container images now
how about how about set up a whole fleet
you set up all fleet already terraform
it right that's the way it works now so
the other thing that I think is a really
interesting change is the very the very
rule of a developer is changing you
don't just write code you're working
with big data you're working with event
streams and IOT data you're starting to
do
science and machine learning who's
written their first machine learning app
so far yeah it's just emerging super
exciting to help help you all go in this
journey together you're you're getting
to know your users you're doing user
experience you're managing products not
just projects and ultimately you're
working as a team to ship great
experiences out to users and customers
and I think it's a pretty amazing change
now cloud is enabling all this right
we're all served on this journey to
evolve together to this new world we we
all have access to this amazing
technology you know you could just get
it as a service everything is available
as a service so I'm pretty sure the next
five years are gonna be even more
exciting than the last five years to
tell that story we wanted to talk to
some community members get some voices
from our community any any community
members here in the room from the Google
developer communities out around the
world
right on okay we made a little video to
show you some of their stories and some
of the things they're working on so with
that I want to roll a little bit of
video for you funny enough you start
with a simple conversation so imagine
it's Election Day 30 40 million people
sure
it's what our software doors allow them
register these people check for
duplicates or if there are any signs of
fraud
can we have a loyalty program where an
average person can earn points every
time they shop for groceries and this
currency effectively becomes a second
source of wealth to pay for everything
from your electricity bills to school
fees and doctor's bills
[Music]
two of my cousin sisters suffer from
breast cancer and
I wound up losing them that's when I
thought we need to do something with
technology to build a new way of doing
breast cancer screening in my graduate
school I was one of two women in a class
of 45 and it kind of got me thinking
that this is not what it's supposed to
be we have this patient called Maria
she's six years old
then she was having these daily seizures
she lived in a remote area in Brazil
where there's no specialists and no one
in the city could help her
I'm a developer during the day but then
during the evening I wear my cape and I
do Google stuff
[Music]
well things are most amazing is being on
Google cloud as a neighborhood Osby
online and available 100% of the time
it's automated health checks security
checks and logs monitoring I use tools
like Star Driver to keep me on top of
all of that Google and the Android
platform have become kind of a backbone
of our entire product ecosystem where we
could actually fill this royalty program
powered by mobile phones we use deep
learning and the technology stack
partenza flow to interpret thermography
which basically measures the temperature
on the chest and then figures out if
there is any abnormal tissue activity
and this can be five to eight years
before a lump is form of faith who
actually helping people to get access to
doctors that they couldn't have without
the stack for example this case with
Maria with Google cloud we connect to
the clinic device measuring Maria
brainwaves sent to the best trial
neurologists in the country 3,000
kilometers away in San Paolo and she
found a cure for Maria and this was
awesome I run the Google developer group
Vancouver chapter I see girls from high
school they actually show up at our
meetups they know nothing about the
product and after like one hour of two
hours of time they can build something
from scratch I'm one of the organizers
of GDG called London we are the most
active GDG cloud
in the world and I love how you can
achieve all these dreams and passions
and ideas you have using the Google top
pop or whatever you you do in life try
to solve a meaningful problem more than
ever people are asking for purpose on
the work that they do you're not just
building product you're building product
that can change people's lives Michael
we will excel in technology women will
get their seats at the table I feel that
Google just empowered me from that
moment it's been love as pillow
so cool thank you
Thank You Amanda and femi and all the
community members so great to hear your
stories so look we're gonna kick off
today we're gonna be a great day but I
really wanted to start with a promise to
you a promise that Google is going to
really do three things the first is
continued to deliver amazing innovation
things like Auto ml and CPUs silicon for
tensorflow at massive scale the second
thing we're gonna do is we're committed
to open source and an open cloud you
know Google's got about 20 years of
experience doing open source and being
part of the open source community under
our belts and we're looking forward to
doing the next 20 years with you and
then the third thing is that community
theme and we wanted to really launch
that at this conference we believe in
being part of the developer community we
are engineers at Google we sit all over
the world with all of you and we want to
continue to be really connected with you
as we as we figure out this next
generation of technology so for the rest
of the morning we have one simple rule
and that is show don't tell we got a lot
of great code it's gonna be a lot of fun
and let's get started yeah right on I
want to introduce a great executive at
Google a vice president engineering
Melanie mcfist is going to talk to you
about tools Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much Adam I'm so happy to be
here today my name is melody McDonald
and I'm passionate about developers
because I am one and I also worked for
many years in operations where I carried
a pager and I became very familiar with
the fair phrase it works well on my
machine so I leave developer and
operator tools at Google this includes
Google engineers Chrome and open-source
developers Android developers and
developers using Google's cloud platform
now each one of us probably has a
different definition of DevOps at Google
our understanding is that DevOps
includes two things end to end automated
tooling from source to build and test to
releasing with integrated observability
and the culture that supports and
enables developers DevOps
is near and dear to my heart because
it's about automating away the toil
while empowering the humans makes us
productive and maybe just a little bit
happy so how many humans in the room
today yeah well humans develop software
and operate services and at Google we've
spent a significant ever understanding
productivity different developers need
different levels of insight and care and
as developers we want to choose the best
DevOps tools to get our work done but
that choice can be hard sometimes
imagine being a new developer and having
to pick your language or framework that
you need to use or where to deploy your
app vm kubernetes or which cloud
platform to use well that one should be
easy right Google cloud platform that's
why we're here and with so many choices
at every stage selecting the right
DevOps tools can be overwhelming and
waste our time at Google our goal is to
make these DevOps
tooling decisions easier for you
that way you can go back to doing what
you love writing code and bringing your
idea to life quickly but moving fast
shouldn't come at the expense of
security or stability because without
that any speed improvements are useless
industry research shows that
high-performing DevOps teams
achieve both faster releases and better
stability they deploy 46 times more
frequently than their low-performing
peers and their production deployments
are seven times less likely to result in
a degraded service so think about that
you get faster releases with better
stability and what explains this
behavior well comes back to this
combination of end-to-end tooling and
the DevOps culture at Google we've
embraced and adopted DevOps cultural
principles first use data to guide your
decisions dig into the code look at logs
look at traces to understand what's
going on how the shared fate and
collaboration between the humans the
developers and operators because we know
we're more powerful when we work
together
choose transparency over secrecy and
siloing everyone sees the same data and
information by integrating observability
into your apps and finally embrace
blameless post-mortems
to encourage continuous improvement
within your teams we have to accept and
learn from our failure I mean this is
software development right we're gonna
have bugs so all of this is super easy
to say but when you live it it's magic
this is how we build trust between
developers and operators we have to
trust each other to make it happen for
our users
so I want to show you today and and
DevOps to lean to help you build deploy
and monitor your apps quickly and safely
our DevOps tools consist of cloud source
repositories a single place to store
manage and track your code
cloud build a fully managed continuous
integration and delivery platform that
lets you build and test your
applications in the cloud at any scale
and stackdriver management tools for
developers and operators so let's walk
through a day in the life of a software
developer and operator we're gonna build
an end an automated pipeline using GCP
devops tools with well-known open source
tools like github and spinnaker we're
gonna go from finding a problem and
stackdriver to using code search
functionality and cloud source
repositories to find the code we're
gonna fix the code we're gonna commit
the change to get hub we're gonna kick
off a build using cloud build and then
we're going to deploy the gke using
spinnaker and we're gonna do all that in
just 10 minutes
Morgan melody awesome to see you great
to see you here hello everybody
all right so let's get started so this
is hipster shop you may remember it from
Tuesday's keynote we're gonna purchase
an item and it is a lot slower than it
was on Tuesday I think it you know its
popularity increased over the last few
days so we're gonna start our
investigation looking at stock driver
trace which is part of our APM suite our
APM suite lets you do production
debugging profiling and tracing on
applications running anywhere and with
google LED projects like open census
we're making it incredibly easy to
extract telemetry from your applications
whatever tools you decide to use so
after looking at some traces we seen a
couple of things first for a single
customer request we see many child
requests so we're just gonna batch those
up it's gonna make it more efficient but
the second thing that we noticed here is
that the request to the catalog service
are incredibly whoa very slow this one's
about 2.6 seconds just for one of them
okay well we're gonna have to dig in on
this so we're gonna go from stackdriver
trace to stack driver profiler which
profiles applications continually with
no appreciable overhead we've been using
profile
Google for many years and now our
customers get to use the same
functionality
so this icicle graph it shows you the
resources consumed by the function on
the horizontal axis and the call
hierarchy on the vertical access so
because things are slow we're gonna go
check out CPU time here and what we can
see looking at profiler is that there's
a really slow G RPC get product method
which is spending all of its time
waiting on this function parse catalog I
think it's taking what is it now yeah
it's bad that's bad yeah that's very bad
so let's go look at parse cattle the
code for parse catalog so this
application code is actually hosted on
github and it's continuously mirrored to
cloud source repositories where you can
use function functionality like powerful
code search and indexing so we're gonna
come here to cloud source repositories
we're gonna search for that function we
saw in profiler and there it is real
quick so let's take a look at the blame
layer wait Morgan Morgan you told me to
slow it down he's responsible for this
one so we're gonna hop to github and
check out that there's a pull request
that's been created that fixes these
performance issues and it's for Morgan
yep got to fix my own bugs amazing so
highly not pull approve the pull request
from Morgan and this is gonna
automatically trigger a cloud build run
which you can see in the cloud build UI
all right there it is so Zendesk lyft
and over a thousand customers use cloud
build daily to ship new functionality so
as a reminder we're doing this all live
the builds gonna take a couple minutes
so let's cross our fingers on this one
at Google we create over 4 million
builds in the cloud every day because
it's flexible it's secure and
scales but right now let's go back and
look at the pull request that we just
approved we can see that cloud build
also ran a test build when the pull
request was created and we did this
because we wanted to make sure that the
pull request wasn't broken now all of
this is being done through our new cloud
build github partnership which we are
excited to announce today with this
partnership developers are able to use
cloud build CI capabilities to validate
changes run tests and get results right
within the github UI in a frictionless
way so it's super easy to get started as
long as you have a github repo with a
docker file in the root directory github
will automatically suggest cloud build
and its CI capabilities you can see it
here and you can get started running
builds in just seconds cloud build makes
high velocity software development safe
easy and secure it really unleashes your
team's productivity so let's check the
build it's almost done almost done
hopefully this is where we need the DJ
to be playing a little bit of music one
of the nice things about cloud Bill does
it show logs right in the console which
you can see here and so it's finishing
the final step right now it's pushing it
up to GC R and now we're done all right
live demo folks so all the tests passed
we're good to go
but I keep mentioning security so I want
to show you cloud build will actually do
security scanning for you so we're gonna
kick off a scan and actually it's so
fast we didn't find any vulnerability
it's we're good to deploy that and if
Morgan if you can show an example of
maybe a past project with some yes you
can see here we wouldn't deploy these
images because we need to fix the issues
first all right so we've done our build
we've done our tests we check for
vulnerabilities cloud build is now going
to trigger a spinnaker pipeline to
the image google has been a core
contributor to the spinnaker open-source
project this was created to make multi
cloud deployments safe fast and secure
so today we're gonna see automated
canary analysis which reduces the risk
associated with deploying to production
so while we're performing the automated
canary analysis we're gonna
automatically promote things because we
don't have a lot of time today but what
you're gonna see this is an actual
pipeline that's running and it has three
stages in the first stage the canary
build is pushed to a single instance of
the app and some traffic is routed to it
in the second phase we would normally
check things like metrics to see how
it's developing but we've kind of
automatically pushed this board because
it'd take about 30 minutes for us to do
this task and in the third stage the
build will promote the canary to all the
remaining production instances and as
you can see the different stages the
color turns from blue to green as it
progresses through the canary analysis
so I'm sure everyone here is familiar
with automated canary announced our
canary analysis itself but quite often
when we do this it's manual and ad-hoc
and therefore it's prone to our own
human bias and error with spinnaker you
can now automatically promote or fail
the canary minimizing your deployment
risk while continuing to release as fast
as you possibly can so assuming that
these chains just look good spinnaker
will automatically push or rollback the
canary using spinnaker ways was able to
create over a thousand production
deliberate pipelines while reducing
their deployment errors by almost 95%
that's pretty amazing
so the deployment is almost done but we
want to show you one last thing which is
the stack driver profiler has this
really great comparison feature which
lets you look at CPU consumption
patterns that change with inversions and
so you can see we're running this on
some older data but you can see how slow
functions will shrink
these are highlighted in blue so let's
go back to the spinnaker pipeline just a
couple seconds left couple seconds left
so I can show you on this profiler view
of the parts catalog function that was
taking up so much CPU time before it's
now effectively fallen to zero which is
probably where it should be so this
comparison view lets us validate that on
that second build that we built even
notice from older data that we fixed
that problem so let's go take a look at
spinnaker again we'll go a couple more
seconds couple more seconds
now this is rolling out on spinnaker to
I think five or six different instances
on kubernetes so like melody mentioned
we took a canary build so we took over
one of those instances with the test
build ran some checks on it for the
purpose of this demo we just made that
always pass once that passes then we go
and deploy that to the remaining
instances within kubernetes oh it's
green it's green live demo folks my
fingers were crossed behind my back so
let's go back to the hipster shop surf
around it's a lot faster a lot faster
all right there we go and an automated
tooling you see gcp DevOps
thanks a lot Morgan thank you awesome
buddy
all right well we want to continue to
collaborate on open source tools like
basil and go and we want to work closely
together within the ecosystem but
collaborating in the ecosystem means
being open and working well with the
tools and technologies that you already
used today so I would just want to take
a second and highlight two ways that
we're committed to be in the open cloud
terraform from hashey Corp is a leading
technology in writing and creating
infrastructure as code we're committed
to making first-class support for
products like terraform and we have a
dedicated team within Google to support
our partners like hashey Corp our
friends at git lab have built a complete
open-source DevOps stack we started
working with them a couple months ago to
integrate with GC gke and it next we're
showing how you can use cloud build to
scale your get lab builds we're also
helping to move get lab comm to run on
top of GC p I believe that through these
collaborations within the ecosystem we
are gonna make it better together so
today you saw stack driver APM tools
including trace and profiler profiler
just went to beta on GC p and our alpha
participants have said they were saving
about 10% of their compute bill with a
less than an hour of work snap was able
to achieve some pretty incredible
optimizations you saw a fast code search
using cloud source repositories and you
saw cloud build the launch of cloud
build automatically run builds and tasks
in the cloud at any scale that included
vulnerability scanning Shopify uses this
feature to scan over 6,000 builds a day
and three hundred and thirty thousand
images in the registry every day and
that's just it's amazing to think about
that scale finally you saw spinnaker
help with deployments and have awesome
features like automated canary analysis
businesses like HSBC
and snap and eBay and PayPal use our
DevOps tools every day to ship new
features and functionality we hope you
will try out these GCP tools today
Google spent the last two decades
iterating on developer and operator
tools every developer and operator
deserves this level of automation speed
and scale we're even more excited about
the things that we're working on that
you're gonna see in the coming year
let's hope you let's help you focus on
the things that you love bringing your
ideas to life
so next up Kelsey Hightower is going to
do a great demo and talk through some of
the tools so I mentioned today thanks so
much for your time and have an awesome
conference
[Music]
oh wow this is like a alternative Tron
universe I've been using kubernetes so
long I finally ended up in the container
[Laughter]
alright so all week we've been learning
about all these new technologies sto
Envoy kubernetes like how do you put all
these things together so I work at
Google and when I think about Google
Cloud I think about things all the way
from my laptop of my Chromebook to the
Maps API and tools like dialog flow so
what I want to do is walk through some
of these things on how I think about
putting these things together now I also
want to show you some of the tricks that
I do so I'm going to start from the
bottom and build a weather application
from zero starting with the database all
the way up to the endpoint now we only
have about 15 minutes we're gonna see if
we can get this all done in time so the
first thing we want to do is kind of
start with this example so here's a
terminal everyone like terminals is that
cool someone's like where's my GUI we'll
get there all right so what I want to do
is maybe start with a few leather
weather locations so these are all of
our regions in the US our newest region
being Los Angeles California and the
goal is I want to take these names and
get weather data now here's a problem I
can't just give these names to the
Weather Service I actually have to give
them geo coordinates ok now I have a
couple of options here I can actually
use the Maps API so the Google Cloud
Maps platform does provide a places API
that can trade those names in and get
back some coordinates or something close
and then once I have those I can
actually send those to the weather gov
and actually get back coordinates here's
the thing I don't have a lot of time to
write all of this code now once you
become a senior engineer I'm going to
teach you a couple of tricks now this is
what all senior engineers do you guys
ready for the first protip now you got
to write some code now this is what we
do you do this if you haven't heard of
Stack Overflow you have no clue what's
going on all right so let's do this
Google Maps
platform like this is high-quality code
that you can find on this thing man
trust me and we'll do weather and then
okay let's go over here alright how do
we do this
Oh code this looks legit alright I'm not
sure who this Terrence Ryan guy is but
you know now this is the Internet so
what you got to do is you got to scan
for those security vulnerabilities all
right you gotta gotta make sure this
stuff is legit hold on let's make sure
we can grab this let's see what we're
gonna do here so let's grab this code
come on I don't care about cookies it's
the Internet how dangerous could it be
where's my copy and paste like why they
trying to sell me stuff I'm trying to
get my job done oh come on like the
hardest part of this alright look at
this ads alright we should be in
business now alright so let's grab this
what you want to do is you want to scan
for security vulnerabilities as you go
through this that looks legit tuck into
a database sure why not cool let's just
grab that so here's the thing oh we
didn't grab it Kylie I should be fired
this is why we use gifts all right copy
so one thing is good programmers copy
great programmers paste
[Laughter]
all right so we got our code now the
next thing we need to do is set up a
database now I am the world's most
average DBA so for me I'm going to use a
hosted database service and I like to
keep it open source so my favorite
database is Postgres and what I'm gonna
do here listen if you're a developer you
need to set up the database there is no
shame in clicking the button click
database BAM like a pro okay you've got
to own it so I got this database set up
and I created a user I actually do not
know how to create a user so I usually
click this button cuz I can't have to
look it up all the time so once I have
the user create it I have a little amv
file so I can use natural tools so the
thing I like about this I can use my
existing tools to do my job so the first
we're going to do here is we're supposed
to get the environment variables for my
connection string in my environment and
then we're going to see if we can
connect to the actual database and I can
let's make sure we don't have any tables
set up so we're starting from scratch
now the next thing I need to do is
actually set up the database schema all
right so there's some sequel list dope
by the way if you don't know sequel you
should learn it okay so P SQL and then
we're just run this create database
command oh we need to get our
credentials so PG that env and then
let's do this and then come on oh oh we
got a database schema and let's make
sure we don't have any data in there all
right we're starting from scratch so the
next thing we're going to do is you're
going to change into that directory
where we've downloaded that production
rady code from the internet and what
we're going to do is we're going to give
it traditions okay so this should be
Cola jit this guy is a nice guy I'm
pretty sure so I'm going to put those
credentials in my environment and then
what we want to do now is just do
something local so I bill code I like to
test locally I do not develop in the
container I test things on my local
machine so here what I want to do is do
a quick build and I'm using the new Vigo
stuff so I can actually do development
work without using a go path so for me
I'm writing everything can go linked and
then what I want to do is just build the
application oh and it compiles that's
legit so let's try it let's see what we
can do so remember the goal is gonna
take locations
and we want to trade them for geo
coordinates so we can then talk to the
Weather Service so let's try that now
so we'll do weather data all right so
look at this is like science geo
coordinates okay all right and then
we're getting the weather data so if
everything is legit we should be able to
do a query and we have the weather data
in our database all right so we're in
business
all right now that we got our weather
data we need somewhere to actually run
our code and also if you have the idea
of running this command from your laptop
in production every day that's not how
you do it you might want to run this
code in a cluster somewhere so we need
some infrastructure so the next thing
you do is we need a kubernetes cluster
there's no other place better to run
your code than kubernetes marketing I've
done my job all right so so here's a
kubernetes cluster but there's something
interesting here so there's a couple of
tricks that I like to do here's my
kubernetes question one thing you can do
that's really nice in TCP you can
actually have multiple node pools so
this is the tin one 10.5 cluster I have
13 nodes here but I actually have those
notes split between two different node
pools now the reason why I'm doing this
is I'm using their first general pool
for my web apps my batch jobs
long-running services but this other
node pool I'm a big fan of Envoy so
you've been hearing a lot about iste ió
but underneath sto this is nice reverse
proxy called envoy and I'm boy if you
can think about it's like a cloud native
replacement for engine X or H a proxy it
has all the things that I need to do
things like rate limiting and timeouts
and retries but I like to actually run
envoy as my edge load balancer even in
GCP it's the same load balancer I run on
my laptop so I want some parity so what
I'm doing is I'm actually running each
of my Envoy instances across these three
nodes using what we call a daemon set
and then the last thing I do to set up
my infrastructure I create a load
balancer that points suggest those three
machines so if you think about it I have
a network appliance running inside of my
cluster no extra hops no IP tables
straight to Envoy then directly to my
apps so with the infrastructure in place
we can start to think about deploying
our code so let's go back to the command
line
quickly so the next thing I want to do
is I don't want to execute this from my
machine so here's a cron job every five
minutes this is going to kick that code
off for me automatically so my goal is
just to push this con job up but
remember the price of admission to
kubernetes
is a container image here's my second
trick that I like to do I have this
saying don't ship build environments
ship artifacts so when I ship when I
build my containers
I actually just build my binaries
locally upload the artifact and only
have docker packaged it in an image with
the scratch base image all right so my
image is roughly are about seven Meg's
and then watch how fast the builds are
if I do it this way so the first thing
I'm going to do is build that
application locally take that binary
push it up to Google cloud build and
cloud builder is going to do all the
work for me you'll notice another thing
here I don't have a docker installed on
my machine I can just push my bills
there and get all of my images so in
just a few seconds we'll have a
container image we're ready to go and
then we can actually use that cron job
in kubernetes we'll keep it running soku
CTO applied - f cron dot yeah mo all
right so you'll notice there will be no
pods created until we hit that
five-minute mark but we'll start
watching just to see when things come up
so in about five minutes you'll see the
cron job kick off and cooperage will
keep a few of them around just in case I
need to troubleshoot alright so the next
thing we're going to do is when I move a
little bit faster now is I need to put
an API in front of this so we're going
to do here is say coop CTL apply F and I
have this weather API service and then
what I'm going to do here is just deploy
that and that's gonna be a little bit
faster because I want it right now I
already have the image on the container
registry it's going to pull it into the
cluster and it's going to start running
now here's the next cool thing that you
can do in gke we've done a lot of work
to make pods first-class citizens
inside of Google Cloud so you'll notice
here every pot and kubernetes gets its
own IP address now the one thing that we
do is we make those IPS native using a
technology we call IP aliases and what
IP a leases does it takes all of those
container IPS and make them first-class
in my be PC so my development boxes a is
a VM inside of my V PC so what I
should be able to do is actually without
any port forwarding or extra hops I
should be able to make a call to my API
servers using the container IP and look
at that directly talking to the
container using a very natural
development flow where I can work on
another app why talking to apps inside
of the cluster that's pretty dope if you
didn't think so
alright so we're moving along here the
next thing we want to do is get a web
front-end again you kind of establish
some patterns here build it build a
container push it up and describe the
kubernetes what you want to do so here
we'll build our weather front-end and
then we'll do this deployment now here's
where things get a little bit of
interesting we're not gonna run one copy
we're gonna let kubernetes run three
copies across that cluster for us now
once all of this is running
I have Envoy in a pre-configured IP and
a DNS address that's pointing to this
particular back here so what I'm gonna
do now is pull this up and we should be
able to hit the weather back in Oh
things are looking good let's see all
right everything seems to be working now
here's the thing I've been the solo
developer this whole time I know the
front-end talks to the API server and
the API server talks to the database but
what happens is someone else on your
team needs to check things out the nice
thing is I've been using open census so
again I don't actually have a service
mesh but you can adopt all these
technologies a la carte so if you want
to add tracing to your application you
can bring in tools like the open census
library that allows you to decorate your
function calls or calls between apps and
send that data to tools like Zipkin or
Jaeger in my case I'm using Google Cloud
so we're going to send it's a stack
driver trace I'm gonna pop over here to
the tracing console and then we're going
to find one of those recent traces so we
can see one that just came in a roughly
around now and we'll click on it and you
can actually see the end-to-end traffic
comes in to the front-end the API and
then API returns but not before talking
to the database now here's a nice thing
if you trace this inside of your
codebase and I click show events I can
come down here and see the exact sequel
query that's being executed at that
particular hop now that gives you the
ability to actually see what's going on
and give people a lot
more insight without checking out the
code all right so we got all the
patterns in place infrastructure tracing
and now we need to think about something
new now we only have about five minutes
left so we're gonna have to simulate
this it's not when your boss shows up
it's like hey we need some new
functionality can you get it done by
Friday all right so the task is on so we
have this infrastructure we got this
nice pattern set up and what we want to
do now start to think about something
cool we can add in we got a web
front-end but that's like so 2017 you
got to have a voice integration with
your app if you want to be cool if you
can't talk to your application you're
probably doing it wrong okay so we want
to do is think about a tool called
dialog flow you're not going to build
your own natural language processing
system from scratch some of you are
probably trying there's a better way so
we're gonna use dialog flow so again
let's walk through the pattern really
quickly we're going to write the
application and then we're going to
build it and push it up now remember the
container image is just a press of
admission so we'll build this up now
here's the other thing you won't be the
sole developer working on this
application forever maybe there's
someone else on the team that wants to
contribute and maybe they have no
interest in writing yamo files or using
kubernetes from the command-line we've
done a lot of work to make sure that
kubernetes works well from the UI so
we'll come over here we'll go to the
kubernetes console and we can click on
workloads now notice here all the things
I did on the command line are reflected
in the gke console now if I have a new
person on the team that's not quite
familiar with kubernetes this could be
their workflow we'll click deploy and
we've done something special here we've
integrated deeply with GCP including the
Google container registry so if I click
on this I can drop down and find that
image that I just created it finds all
the right tags hit select and then it
fills out everything I need underneath
let's give this a name we'll call it the
weather assistant we have the right
labels and if I have multiple clusters I
can choose where should deploy now if
you want to see what's going on
underneath the hood you can actually
display that sweet
sweet yeah mo that you love so much and
then we also give you a autoscaler to
make sure you can respond to traffic
changes and we'll hit deploy so that's
gonna do all the heavy lifting for me
right through the UI and just like that
it should be deployed we'll switch over
here and we can see the weather
assistant is now ready serving traffic
now as next thing we're going to do is
make sure that we're ready by checking
the health check so here's the DNS name
that I've assigned to this particular
app well hit it we see everything is UPS
working and we can also see all my track
is flowing through envoy I should be in
good shape
alright so we only have a few minutes
left let's see if we can pull this last
piece off so I'm going to log into the
dialogue flow console this is also part
of the Google cloud platform so dialogue
Pro allows you to design these voice
integrations with your application so
we'll come here there's a couple things
we need to do first
we need to make sure that our users have
a good time with our application so
we're going to do is we're gonna define
all this verified inputs and create a
few synonyms just in case you want to
say things like Los Angeles or Los
Angeles California USA to talk to the
weather app the next thing we're going
to do is describe their intent what does
our user want to do so here we want to
have them check the temperature now
there's no way I'm going to define
everything or every phrase our users
would do so here what I'm gonna do is
give dialog flow a few training phrases
and notice how it's automatically
pulling out those regions that match the
entities that I described before so
we're ready to go now I want to send
this to our web hub that we just got
deployed so we'll come here we have a
couple more steps
we'll go to fulfillment and in
fulfillment you'll see that I'm just
putting in that same URL that I had
earlier that's pointing to my kubernetes
stack all right you have all kind of
integrations that you can do but this
time we just want to do the Google
assistant now this whole time I've been
using my pixel book to do this demo and
this is something I also think a part of
the end-to-end experience at Google so
we want to test out this now I could use
the simulator or I can actually come
down here and use my laptop now to prove
that this is real we're going to look at
the logs for the assistant to make sure
Kelsey isn't cheating
all right so coop CTL logs well give it
that container name and we just chained
the logs here so we can see it's
listening but there's nothing there yet
so if I hit the assistant button on my
pixel book we should be able to talk to
this thing yeah whatever
all right talk to the talk to the local
weather service sure here's the test
version of local weather hello Kelsey
hello looks like you have a pretty large
crowd here I hope the demo gods are on
your side I hope so too all right so
let's give this a go what's the current
temperature in Los Angeles California
the current temperature in Los Angeles
California USA is 82 degrees Fahrenheit
thank you okay I gotta admit that was
pretty dope and what that you kind of
saw the into end Google experience
starting with my laptop all the way to
the data model I can use open source
tools like cloud sequel Postgres then I
can actually use the industry standard
kubernetes backed by Cooper Naoki ke
then I have my choice of load balancer
so I can use for familiar tools like I'm
for Engine X and then I can use things
like open census to add some visibility
to my application and visualize all that
and stackdriver trace and then I can
move on to try new ideas like adding
voice integration to my application all
within the Google cloud platform and
with that I'd like to introduce our next
speaker Audra who's going to come out
and talk more about languages thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Asha Annihilator programming
language's efforts on the Google cloud
developer advocacy scene developer
advocacy team I like working in
developer relations at Google because
this was job let's engineers like myself
spend her time helping people build cool
things and giving back to our tech
communities my community has given me a
lot over the years and I'm really
grateful that I get this chance to give
back and I work on languages because I'm
kind of a giant language nerd
I'd love to talk to you about all the
languages I enjoy using but they only
gave me time to talk to you about two of
them today so the first language we're
gonna talk about is go-go is growing so
much right now
Taron estimated 1 million Gophers
worldwide but more practically when I go
to my local DevOps meetup go is the
language we talk about the most folks
are using it for lots of stuff like
building micro services and improving
their operations and so I'm like hey
guys what's with the gum and it gave me
lots of reasons they liked it first off
it's the languages of the containers
world almost everything Kelsey just
showed was written and go including
docker and kubernetes and go is great
for systems level programming because
it's fast and it was built from the
ground up with concurrency support for
those coming from languages where
concurrency was kind of tacked on later
having concurrency was a first-class
concept is really delightful and folks
also like the gos developer friendly
there are very few keywords and it uses
familiar syntax and Gophers rave about
how easy it is to write how it has the
speed of a compiled language and all the
benefits of static typing and all of
that leads to faster performance reduced
QA time and fewer errors in production
personally
my favorite thing about go is the
welcoming and supportive community of
passionate Gophers throughout the world
so today I want to talk about the new go
cloud project from Google this library
provides Gophers with cloud agnostic
abstractions for services like
relational data stores runtime configs
and blob storage so that's a bunch of
words but let's say you have an
application
uses google cloud storage and storage on
some other provider currently you have
to have two different branches in your
code one for each provider you have to
remember that maybe one provider uses
the method list bucket contents to see
what's in a bucket and the other uses
something I don't know maybe describe
bucket and it's doing the same thing but
I don't want to have to keep all that in
my head I am lazy and the go cloud
project helps with this by providing one
set of objects and methods that work
with multiple cloud providers you don't
have to learn an API for each provider
you can use one method and the go cloud
project takes care of translating it to
the right method for that cloud or maybe
even multiple methods and the return
data is consistent between clouds you
don't have to worry about doing all
sorts of cloud specific type checking
the big thing though is that with the go
cloud project your application code
doesn't need to be aware of what
backends you're using or even if you're
using multiple clouds the API provides
allows you to set your application code
from the configuration needed to concept
to the connect to the cat out loud
so you can focus on the fun stuff like
adding new features Ino from the
advocacy team is with us today and he's
gonna demonstrate the cloud front go
cloud project so Ino has an application
that uploads a photo to cloud storage on
either GCP or AWS and of course we're
gonna upload a picture of a gopher so
here's the application code that runs
that and you can see that in each method
we have a top-level conditional for
choosing between the two clouds we have
to support and under each branch the
code is similar but it's not entirely
the same each cloud is initialize a
little differently and it provides
objects with different methods for
handling the results you get back from
storage and I've written code like this
but I'm not particularly proud of it
because it's really gross
and here's the thing we can do a lot
better so here's a version of the code
that uses the go cloud project the first
thing you're gonna see is that that
top-level conditional is gone
what we've done is we separated the
application laundry from the storage
configuration and to make it really
clear here's the diff between the two
versions adam promised yellow def here's
the diff you can see that there's a lot
less code in the version that uses the
go cloud library and even better the
code that uses the library has a better
design because we've separated the two
concerns better engineering practices
lead to more maintainable code thank you
you know if you've ever had to support
multiple clouds in a single application
you know that using a four library like
the go cloud project is a much easier
way to do things and it encourages good
engineering practice but library authors
can also build on top of the go cloud
project to ensure that folks on any
provider can use their library our hope
is that this project will foster an
ecosystem of libraries built with multi
cloud portability in mind the go cloud
project is of course open source
currently supports AWS and GCP but more
clouds are coming soon and of course
contributions welcome
so the second language I want to talk
about today is JavaScript JavaScript was
the most popular language on github last
year there were so many more JavaScript
commits as there were for any other
language it's really remarkable and I
know I've written a bunch of JavaScript
in my career and I'm assuming most of
you have as well Google has been a
champion of the JavaScript language for
a really long time some of Google's
JavaScript projects include angular amp
polymer and the v8 engine it's at the
heart of nodejs and javascript is one of
those fantastic languages that you can
use just about anywhere for just about
anything if you told me in 1995 that I'd
be writing server-side JavaScript I
wouldn't have believed you but the async
features is something like nodejs help
you build fast scalable web back applet
that web application backends and
node.js is also the default language for
functions as a service but it can be
used for non web applications too like
robotics and
javascript is as popular as ever from
building rich client-side interactive
experiences so if you go out and learn
javascript there really isn't much you
can't do the community has been asking
for nodejs on App Engine standard and
we're happy to say that it's in beta no
date can be used just like your other
App Engine language and you can use most
of your favorite and PM modules and if
you don't know App Engine is GCPs
platform as a service product it's been
around for a long time we just
celebrated the 10th anniversary and it
all of the fans of App Engine like the
ease-of-use auto-scaling
security and how well it integrates with
all the other GCP products like
datastore and with this nodejs now runs
on every single compute that GCP offers
I told you you can do anything with
known so it's really important to me and
all of my friends over there dressed in
red on the cloud developer relations
team the Google is an active participant
and a good citizen in our developer
communities after all the best tools are
written by developers who understand a
community's needs and idiosyncrasies and
we like to put our code where our mouth
is and we do that by contributing to
improving the languages and surrounding
ecosystems so that's why Google cloud is
a platinum sponsor of the node
foundation and it's also why there are
many Googlers participating in node in a
variety of roles giving their time and
expertise to help guide the future of
the language so they'd only give me a
couple of minutes today and so I was
only able to talk about a few of the
popular languages and even then I only
focused on their server-side uses but
client mobile development are important
and growing too so next you're going to
hear from Sam and Francis and they're
gonna talk about firebase development
and development with gzp products for
mobile
[Music]
Thanks aha our mission for firebase is
to help mobile app team succeed by
providing you a platform to help solve
the key problems across the lifecycle of
your app from building your app to
improving your app quality to growing
your business we've come a long way
since two years ago when we expanded
firebase from a real-time database to a
broad app development platform and it's
so exciting to see there are now over
1.2 million apps actively using firebase
every month including many of the top
Android and iOS apps like the New York
Times box and Pandora now as you've
heard earlier Google Cloud offers a wide
variety of products to help you build
secure and scalable infrastructure so
when it comes time to build your mobile
app for your business
firebase integrates smoothly with GCP to
help you build better and faster to show
you how easy it is to build an app with
firebase I like to welcome one of my
teammates Sam to join us
hello Thank You Francis so one of the
first problems that most mobile app
developers face is finding a way to
store and sync their data in the cloud
ideally without managing any
infrastructure cloud firestore was built
to solve this problem on every platform
that you work on it's a fully managed no
sequel database built on Google's global
infrastructure now let's say I'm the
developer of a financial services app
called a next wallet my users have been
asking me for a long time to add a
mobile app to complement the web app
firebase helps you build apps on Android
iOS and the web but today I'm just gonna
focus on building an Android app so here
are in the firebase console you can see
I've already got all my data in cloud
fire store this is a list of my recent
transactions I went to Sam's place and I
spent about $45
moving over to Android studio I want to
load all of my transactions here I won't
display the users recent transactions so
let's do that here
okay so what I'm doing here is I'm
getting the ID of the currently signed
in user and then you can see here I'm
forming a query using the firestore
Android SDK we're asking for the users
latest 50 transactions ordered by time
you'll also notice I can query this data
directly from my app without building
any API servers or proxies I'm accessing
the remote data as if it was in a local
database so if I run this in the
emulator you can see that all of the
transactions from the console are now
displayed an app and this connection is
completely real-time by default so if I
go to the console and change the name on
one of the places change Sam's place to
Sam's awesome place it updated in the
app before we could even switch screens
so with barely any code my mobile app is
showing the same data as my web app in
real time now if you're used to
accessing a database via REST API you
may have found it strange I did not
include any tokens or headers in my
request
that's because cloud firestore
automatically detects that I'm signed in
with firebase authentication and
includes that all state transparently so
every request from my app to Cloud
firestore is checked by firebase rules
which is a declarative system for
controlling access to firebase resources
so let's see the rules that are keeping
this app safe so these are my custom
security rules here I'm making sure that
users can only read and write their own
data and here I've locked down rights to
transactional information to prevent any
sort of spoofing it's really powerful to
have direct client access to your data
without running any authentication
servers or API proxies it completely
streamlines your development process and
even more importantly it reduces the
surface for bugs or for vulnerabilities
now with sensitive applications like
this finance app you can't do everything
on the client-side if we need to add
some critical business logic I'll want
to run it in a trusted location so the
newest feature in my app is that users
can pay their bills and unlike viewing
recent transactions this is a really
privileged operation so moving here I'll
write a server list nodejs function to
pay a
bill from the users bank account and
then market has paid and I'll deploy
this whole thing to Club functions you
can see here that I've got a function
it's called pay bill and after the bill
is paid it marks the paid state to true
in fire store now in the Android app we
can simply call this function by its
name pay bill the same name I defined
and we can pass in the ID of the bill we
want to pay after the function runs
I'll get this callback here with the
result just like with the data called a
cloud fire store our authentication
state is passed seamlessly in the
request so users can only access their
own bills so now let's use it let's pay
a bill hit this here and what just
happened was the cloud function ran and
made the update which was detected by
the client in real time so in just the
last few minutes we set up a secure
scalable on real-time connection to our
data and also deployed a cloud function
to perform trusted actions which is
pretty impressive right
once your once your app is billed you'll
likely be looking to improve your app
stability and performance since the
first-impression gap makes is crucial to
the long-term success of your business
I've seen through Google Play that 42%
of one-star reviews mentioned
instability or bugs
whereas 73% of five-star reviews
mentioned design usability or speed so
having a stable and speedy app is
essential to your success so let's
switch it back over to Sam to take a
look some of the ways that firebase
helps you improve your app quality so as
a mobile developer I have to release my
code into the wild and it could end up
on any kind of device or any network I
need to know how it's performing and
more importantly I need to know when
it's crashing if I wait to hear about
crashes and bad Play Store reviews
that's way too late so all I have to do
to track crashes in this app is add the
single line dependency on crashlytics I
don't have to write a line of real
Android code now let's go into the
firebase console and see what crashes
are happening for my users so here I can
see that I had a crash but I don't know
why yet
let's take a look at the trace I can see
that it was a fatal exception I can see
the exact line where it occurred I can
also see some information about the
device where it happened and the
environment through an integration with
slack I could get new crashes like this
sent to me and my team in real time now
here in the logs panel I can see we have
a list of analytics events that preceded
the crash event logging from Google
Analytics to crash Lois's crashlytics is
automatic and it provides really helpful
context it's now I have a ton of
information on what the user is doing to
cause the crash which allows me to debug
my app more efficiently I could spend
more of my time and my team's resources
on building features for my users and
now that we can measure if the app is
stable I still need to directly measure
the goals of my business so for the new
build a future I want to make sure that
users are able to find the tab in the
app pay the bill and that it all runs
successfully firebase provides free
unlimited mobile analytics and
automatically measures common events in
your app but I want to add custom
analytics for each bill pay event for
the attempt success and the failure so I
can track user behavior here so if we
move back into Android studio in the
bill paid flow I'll add calls around the
common parts of the flow so you're all
logged the attempt here all logged in
succeeds and here all logged when it
fails you can see that for each event I
just pick a name and then I pass a
bundle of parameters now that the codes
running if I go back into the app and
pay a bill those events will fire
heading back into the console I can see
these events coming in in real time by
defining custom events you can measure
the things that uniquely matter to your
business analytics is the backbone of
firebase and the foundation for a
successful business having the right
analytics is the first step to ensure
your users are happy and your app is
doing the job you want it to do but once
you have the data you want to put it to
work for your business with firebase you
can export your analytics data into
bigquery join it with other data sources
and perform deeper analysis
you can also take action right directly
from the firebase console and it comes
to the built in a/b testing framework so
for example you can send push
notifications or test different
configurations of your app without
having to redeploy to the App Store or
Google Play with a be testing you can
define different variants set the
primary and secondary goals for your
experiments and the system will
automatically do the hard work for you
to help you find the optimal variant and
once you have the winner you can roll
that experience out to the rest of your
user base without another app deployment
firebase also helps you take targeted
action by leveraging machine learning
now it's one thing to take action based
on past user behavior but with firebase
predictions you can apply ml to your
analytics data to take targeted actions
based on predicted future behavior so
for example you can send special offers
to users poor likely to leave your app
or in Sam's example he can send push
notifications targeted to users who are
likely to miss a bill payments so
predictions was the first step that we
took to bring the power of Google's ml
to work for you two months ago we took
our second step with the release of ml
kits in public beta with ml kits we're
bringing together machine learning
technologies from across Google and
making that available to every mobile
developer working on Android and iOS ml
kit comes with five AP eyes out of the
box like image labeling and text
recognition and you can run these ap
eyes on device for low latency
processing or in the cloud for higher
levels of accuracy and if you have more
sophisticated needs you can upload your
own custom tensorflow lite model and
serve that through Google's global
infrastructure your app can dynamically
retrieve these models and evaluate them
on device so that means you don't need
to bundle the model with your app binary
and you can update it without pushing it
and app updates and since ml kit is
available through firebase it makes it
easy for you to take advantage of the
broader firebase platform for example
experimenting with different custom
models using a be testing or storing
your
[ __ ] label into cloud firestore or
understanding the impact on user
engagement with Google Analytics we are
so excited about the possibilities that
machine learning unlocks whether it's
the supercharger growth or build amazing
user experiences we want to harness
Google this advances to help you build
and grow apps and with that I like to
hand it over to you Fang to talk more
about cloudy I thank you
[Music]
Thank You Francis hi everyone my name is
you fan glow and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google cloud over the
past four years that I've been at Google
machine learning has taken on a greater
and greater prominence in both Eric's
internal usage as well as in our
external offerings today I want to
provide you with a users guide to
thinking about machine learning problems
we'll talk about how to find the right
tools for your task depending on your
needs and we'll discuss four groups of
tools and workflows that can be used to
drive insights to build your
applications machine learning api's data
processing model building and scaling up
let's start with api's say you have some
video or sound data now you want to
annotate with labels and transcripts
historically this would have been a
challenging and manual task the video
intelligence API allows you to turn a
video into a set of labels and scenes to
build understanding while the speech API
can turn sound into text
this means you can now focus on doing
something useful with your newly tagged
audio and video files instead of getting
stuck on how to label and transcribe it
all additionally there is the video API
the natural language API and the
Translate API which trend handle images
text and the many languages of the world
enabling you to easily transform an
augment your existing data together you
can think of these five api's as simple
building blocks for your application
they're literally just REST API is that
you can call and get JSON back now if
these pre-trained api's don't give quite
enough detail for you you can customize
them to produce state-of-the-art models
using auto ml for vision natural
language and translation all you need to
do is provide the data for your specific
use case an auto ml will train up a
custom API endpoint just for your
particular interest so that's the story
of the machine learning ap is easy to
use and simple to customize but what
about other forms of data let's say
you've got a data scientist at your
company
or perhaps you are the data scientist at
your company and this data scientist she
is chomping at the bit to get her hands
on as many data sets as possible to find
interesting relationships that might
exist but alas your data is big and it's
messy it's stored in a variety of
formats and places how can we use
machine learning to get some meaningful
outcomes out of this well pile of data
first I want to clarify that machine
learning is not magic but rather it
essentially boils down to using many
examples to make predictions or at least
try to make predictions and so a large
part of the work is around getting the
data organized and because data is often
stored in a variety of places for good
reason I'm sure gathering it together
where possible is a good first step
before then trying to see and get a
sense of just what it is you're dealing
with and how might you do that on JCP
perhaps you explore it in bigquery run
some pre-processing on data flow or data
proc and take a peek at the results in a
jupiter notebook or perhaps you run the
data through data prep and output the
results to cloud storage and save some
metadata to cloud sequel however you
approach it careful management of your
data is the key factor in being able to
do any kind of meaningful analysis and
of course machine learning so be a good
steward to your data and it will reward
you okay so let's say we've got all our
data set up and we're ready to go it's
been turned inside out upside down and
arranged just right what's the next step
in our data scientists journey it's time
for her to make some models if she's
already got a data set stored in
bigquery thanks to all that work and
getting the data prepared it may be
worth running some say linear
regressions directly in sequel using
bigquery and now and for a more
sophisticated approach she can look to
tensorflow Google's popular open source
deep learning library it's flexible and
extensible but best of all runs on all
manner of platforms from CPUs and GPUs
as well as mobile and web initially
she'll most likely run tens for foil on
her local environments say in a Jupiter
notebook maybe she samples
subset of the larger data set from the
cloud and builds a few different models
tread to try out different ideas she has
running tensorflow models against a
subset of the data is all well and good
but then when it comes time to train
some models on the full real data set
running everything on her local laptop
is probably not so realistic just
getting the data downloaded would take a
while so if we can't bring the data down
to the models
let's bring the models to the data by
running machine learning in the cloud
imagine being able to train a model in
the cloud by just sending up your
tensorflow code and virtually nothing
else that's basically what training a
model on cloud ml engine is like you can
train a tensorflow model at scale
without needing it to configure machines
or install libraries you just don't have
to fiddle with that stuff now this has
three very important implications first
it means you can kick off multiple
training jobs in parallel allowing you
to try out different approaches with
different data sets and then well you
can just go get a coffee
second cloud a null engine features a
hyper parameter tuning service that runs
in parallel and uses Bayesian
optimization to try different variants
of the same model and find the one that
has the best performance and third
running tensorflow training on cloud ml
engine gives you access not only to CPUs
and a whole lot of GPUs but also TP use
Google's custom accelerator chip built
for deep learning now once your model is
done training it's time to serve
predictions and as most of you know
standing up a production server is no
easy feat but with cloud and L engine
there are just three steps are you ready
step one provide a name for this version
of your model it can be whatever you
want
let's call ours version awesome step two
provide a location where the exported
model file lives and step three click
Save okay so we did our three steps what
did that get us we've actually already
got ourselves an auto scaling REST API
that can be called from any
internet-connected device on the planet
and if you thought that's neat waits you
find out you can also run your existing
model
that are using seis I could learn an
extra boost on cloud ml engine as well
so you can have just one workflow to
train and deploy models to the cloud
regardless of whether it's using
traditional approaches or deep learning
approaches machine learning it's not
easy but when you take our suite of
cloud native service tools to ingest
transform and manage your data and then
combine it with tensorflow and cloud ml
engine you'll be well equipped to
journey into the next generation of
intelligent applications if you're ready
to dive deeper into machine learning and
data science check out cloudy eye
adventures on YouTube which explores the
art science and tools of machine
learning you can catch it at YouTube /
AI adventures but I know videos aren't
for everyone so here to tell you more
about where you can find a community of
learners who are supporting each other
to grow in their skills and sharing
their knowledge is Anthony Goldblum CEO
of taggle
[Music]
so thanks you Fang I'm Anthony goblin
CEO of CEO of Cargill and it's really
nice to be back on the next stage it was
actually on this stage last year that we
announced that Kaggle was joining Google
so for those of you who don't know Carol
we are the world's largest machine
learning community we're gonna pass 2
million members in the next couple of
weeks now at the beginning of the show
Adam asked how many of you had deployed
a machine learning model and it seems
like not very many and we want to change
that we want to be a part of your entire
machine learning journey our community
ranges from people just learning Python
through to the researchers behind deep
neural networks capital rankings are
probably the most widely recognized
machine learning credential at this
point and so we see many in our
community going from being total newbies
to having elite AI roles so the cowgirl
community started out with machine
learning competitions so and so a lot of
you will think of Cargill as machine
learning competitions but we've expanded
well beyond that if you're a Suffolk
software engineer you go to Stack
Overflow for your question answering and
you've got a github for code
collaboration
well cowgirls trying to do is be the one
place you go for your as a community
member as a member of the machine
learning community we're giving you the
one destination you need to go and so in
addition to competitions we offer
several other things we offer cattle
learn which is short for AI edge
education we offer cattle kernels which
is a cloud-based workbench for data
science and machine learning and we have
a data sets platform where we have
almost 10,000 data sets that have been
shared among our community and so I'm
going to give you a tour of each of
these parts of Cargill and help to show
you how they fit into your machine
learning journey so if you're brand new
to AI and machine learning I suggest
starting with cattle learn as I
mentioned this is very short form AI
education though so if you go to Udacity
the main machine learning course takes
six months cattle learn has you training
your first deep neural network in 30
minutes now we're not teaching you
everything there is to know about deep
neural networks in 30 minutes but what
we are doing is we're giving you enough
of a basis to get going on your own
projects so we have a cloud-based
environment called Cargill kernels and
you can use it with cattle learn but
actually you can use it for most machine
learning projects now
Huggle Cargill kernels allows you to
avoid the pain of setting up your own
environment so we give you a cloud-based
environment and a browser in the browser
that will give you missing with most of
the major packages that you could want
you know we believe we are strong
believers that the future of data
science and machine learning is going to
be done in the cloud in an environment
while capital capital kernels hopefully
Cargill kernels for you and the reason
being is that machine learning workloads
are very bursty one minute you train it
you're exploring a data the next minute
you're training a very large deep in
your network so the cloud is perfect for
such workloads so you can that you can
with Cargill kernels you choose between
a Jupiter notebook interface or a normal
IDE you choose between Python and R so
those are the two main data science
machine learning languages and by
default we give you a cpu but you cannot
you can also have access to a GPU if you
want more compute you can see your data
sets and and see previews of your data
set and the code executes in our servers
on a lot of sorry on Google cloud
servers so you get six hours of compute
per session at no cost so actually this
will cover the majority of your machine
learning workloads okay so to recap
you'll learn you've learnt an algorithm
through Cavill kernels you have an
environment set up now you're ready to
start working on a project and we have
two projects at Cabell that you can you
can work on we have capital competitions
and we have our data sets platform now
the way competitions work is a company
will post a problem and data scientist
machine learners compete to build the
best algorithm on that problem so at any
point in time we're running ten to
fifteen competitions right now if you
come to the site you'll see we're
working with Zillow to improve the
Zestimate home valuation algorithm and
we're also working with CERN to build an
algorithm that better detects particle
collisions in the Large Hadron Collider
I like showing those two use cases
because they give you a sense of sort of
the breadth of machine learning and how
its applicators are totally different
use cases right and it's applicable to
both now during the competition you can
see on there the second cube you can see
a live leaderboard which shows you how
you're performing relative to others so
it also shows you if you're not in first
place it shows you how much better it's
possible to do so if you're scoring 50%
somebody
scoring 90% they've found something that
you haven't found very rewarding also
while you're participating in the
competitions we have forums where people
are sharing techniques and ideas and so
you never run out of ideas of things to
try all you need to do is read the
forum's if you're running out of ideas
and actually at the end of the
competition very often what we'll see is
we'll see that the top performers will
share the the results of their model in
the forums or sorry the the approach
they talk so you kind of get to learn
what the right answer is all right so
our data sets platform is the other
place you can go and do projects and
this is really good for freeform more
free-flowing projects and our community
has shared almost 10,000 data sets at
this point so if you even if you have
your own data set that you want to work
on rather than then then working in
isolation on your local machine you know
why not bring it to kaggle and then
others who are also interested in that
data set will work on it with you right
you'll attract like a small community of
people who are interested in the problem
you're working on on the foot side if
you don't have a data set that you're
itching to work with as I said we have
almost 10,000 data sets and and the
range of topics is kind of breathtaking
I'll show you in a minute but there is
almost certainly a data set that meets
your interests so I'm going to show you
what it looks like to work on our data
sets platform here I'm browsing the data
sets that others have uploaded now find
a data set on avocado prices I like
avocado toast so I figure I'll jump into
this one and rather than starting from
scratch I I start looking at what others
have done on this data set now notice
that somebody called Samuel Belko has
already written a forecasting model and
his forecasting model has done exactly
the kinds of things that I would want to
do you can see I'm scrolling quickly but
you can see he's done some exploration
he's doing some charting then he uses a
you know quite a well-known
timeseriesforecasting package in order
to make a prediction so you can see I
hit the fork button and that gives me
when I hit fork what's happening behind
the scenes is I'm forking the code the
docker container and the connection to
the data so I get his in his code in an
environment that will run it immediately
and you can see I'm scrolling through I
have exactly the same code that he has
and then when I start execute
sells its executed I'm getting the same
results that he that he gets so as I dig
into his results
I noticed that our baccardo prices rose
pretty dramatically in 2017 and I want
to build a model that sort of fits that
period nicely and explains that period
nicely so I go in and I add a dataset
and I add a dataset with Starbucks
locations which at first glance sounds
kind of odd what our Advocaat o prices
and Starbucks locations have to do with
each other well it turns out that
Starbucks rolled out in avocado spread
nationwide in 2017 and so when I added
in a dataset on Starbucks locations it
helps me to to you know to feel it to
evaluate the impact of the additional
Starbucks demand on avocado prices so
you can see how I can go and extend
Samuels model by adding in an extra data
set and adding that data set into the
model if I wanted to grab weather data
as well you know almost certainly we
have a weather data set for some of the
main growing regions advocator growing
regions so maybe that had an impact on
supply so hopefully that gives you a
sense for for how much you know how many
learning opportunities how many
interesting datasets how much there is
to do on the cake cattle data sets
platform so as I said at the beginning
capital wants to be a part of your whole
machine learning journey and so over the
coming year you'll start to see us
adding more commercial-grade features
you'll see you'll start to see us allow
you to connect your capital accounts to
your GCP accounts you'll be able to
access the data sets you have in
bigquery you'll be able to deploy your
models to cloud ml engine and so you'll
get the both the content that has been
shared with the caracal community plus
the power of GCPs data analytics and
machine learning services so for those
of you who aren't yet haven't yet
deployed your first machine learning
model who aren't yet a part of our
community we love to say we'd love you
to sign up we want to help accelerate
your machine learning journey and so
kaggle is one other great communities
around GCP but next on stage we have Sam
O'Keefe who heads up Google cloud for
startups and Sam is going to talk about
some of the other communities we have
around GCP thank you
thanks Anthony Kaggle and GCPs machine
learning tools are just a few examples
of the way that Google's values manifest
in the tools and technology we create I
hope you've heard by now but just in
case we are committed to openness and we
want all of you the community involved
next up we'll hear from one of our close
partners who shares those values unity
technologies we recently announced that
GCP would be powering the unity platform
with this seamless integration game
developers get to focus on what they
love being creative and building
immersive experiences for their users
while we take care of the infrastructure
let's take a peek
[Music]
here to tell us more
please welcome Suhail Dada VP of cloud
services for unity
at Unity we believe the world's a better
place with more creators in it so
whether we're helping Steven Spielberg
shoot ready player one on Virtual Set or
working with NASA on visualizing the
Mars rover empowering Lexus to design
and market the LC 500 or providing ludia
with the tools to create Jurassic world
alive unity is the most widely used
real-time 3d development platform and
we're empowering millions of creators to
achieve their aspirations at unity we
live by three principles democratize
development solve hard problems enable
success one of the hardest problems in
gaming is building what we call
connected games so games that help their
players connect and play with each other
are easily the most influential games
out there they're the most played the
most watched and the most successful in
fact 90% of the top grossing apps on
Google Play are connected games but
creating them is hard building an
experience that delights your users all
across the world requires a lot of
infrastructure the time and expertise to
manage it and 24/7 support at unity we
want to change that and so does Google
last month we announced a strategic
alliance to help simplify the
development of connected games and we're
doing this keeping two tenets in mind
scalable and approachable scalable so
you can create your game the right way
from day one whether you have one player
or a million and we do this with
efficient high
performance networking an
enterprise-grade server hosting we also
use our tools and services to provide a
seamless integration between unity and
Google cloud so you can get started
quickly and focus on what you do best
creating great experiences our first
collaboration a service that helps match
players into games based on an
open-source matchmaking project is
coming out later this summer it's called
open match not only do we believe the
Google cloud is the right cloud for our
customers but we're also migrating our
infrastructure over to Google cloud
together we're making it easier for you
to build and operate your connected
experiences we can't wait to see what
you create thank you Unity's developer
community continues to demonstrate that
with the right tools small teams can
build products that reach and are
enjoyed by millions I have the unique
opportunity to witness this every day as
part of Google cloud for startups at
Google cloud for startups we help
developers from all over the world get
their businesses up and running on GCP
we do this by providing access access to
content to help you learn and technical
mentors for when you get stuck access to
Google products at a discounted rate so
they're affordable when you're in your
garage phase and most importantly access
to a community a community of peers
facing and solving the same technical
and non-technical challenges that you
are in keeping with our theme of
openness Google cloud for startups truly
is for everyone from two developers
working on their first MVP to a team
that just found product market fit and
is figuring out how the heck are we
gonna keep this thing going
Google wants to be there you can get
started today by going to our website
and we'd love to meet you
in the past year thousands of startups
have made the decision to build with
Google you saw a few of these startups
in the video earlier but they're really
doing everything they're leveraging
machine learning to structure healthcare
data using IOT devices to create
factories of the future and if you're
here in the Bay Area they're putting
everything on the blockchain today I'm
excited to have two startups here to
share their story and show us all what's
possible with Google cloud as we heard
in ahsha's talk earlier javascript is
one of the most popular languages today
so our first startup might be familiar
to many of you
NPM provides the largest software
registry in the world
enabling over 11 million j/s developers
to build web applications please join me
in welcoming CTO CJ Silverio as she
tells us how a team of three engineers
gets it done
[Music]
how many of you here work for a company
that has a website website anyway your
company has a website great you are my
user hi I'm CJ Silverio a CTO of NPM Inc
now epi empowers the world's largest
registry of open source software if you
have a website use any modern front-end
framework your developers type NPM
install you use us because we're how the
world shares JavaScript I'm here today
because our team took our global
registry and created an enterprise of
ready version of it to help developers
at big companies use open source code at
work we did it using google kubernetes
engine NPM registry is a complex
distributed system it stores data in
three different databases and a cloud
object store and has the usual thicket
of micro services shuttling that data
around it was designed to make it easy
for us to scale the registry to a
billion downloads a day supporting our
11 million users all of you it's massive
it's reliable to the point that people
don't even think about what happens when
they type in p.m. install here's the
twist
we had Enterprise companies asking us
how they could have their own private
NPM registry all the features of the
public registry but meeting their
greater need for control over their
source code the challenge was to take a
super redundant architecture that
sprawls across hundreds of cloud
instances and package it into something
easy to install manage and operate now
that's a lot of complexity that has to
be reduced and delivered to a single
customer don't issue that NPM is a small
company because we are and we already
have a full-time job running the world's
largest registry of open source software
containerization was clearly the way for
us to go with this and for the first
version of this product we containerized
but we did that with a hand-tuned single
sized container deployment and we ended
up with something that was hard to scale
and hard to update we looked at doing
another take on it we knew we had to use
kubernetes now just saying yeah
kubernetes is not an answer you have to
install kubernetes you have to manage it
and you have to operate it in then you
have to scale that to demand as we bring
in new customers and as our customers
grow and add users and packages so the
idea of building all this infrastructure
ourselves was daunting google kubernetes
engine though had exactly the API we
needed it might sound like a line fed to
me by marketing but it's literally true
give me a cluster here are my compute
memory requirements go gke gives me a
cluster now I need a place to store my
customer's data and keep it backed up
Google Cloud Storage is right there now
I need isolation so I can manage and
Bill each of our customers separately we
use GC p's projects within our Google
Cloud organization to keep our customers
resources isolated so no joke few months
later a single team of three developers
built and shipped an all new NPM
enterprise and it's serving customers
now you can run the exact software that
the NPM registry runs with your own
authentication in a single turnin
environment all on Google Cloud we can
provision a cluster skelet keep our
customers upgraded and I didn't need to
hire a staff that's expert in kubernetes
to do it enterprise customers get all
the features the Public Registry gets at
the same time against them using gke
shaved a year off of our development
time that let us focus on what we do
best building amazing software and pins
mission is to reduce developer friction
for every single software developer in
the world gke reduced
friction for us so we can deliver this
amazing thing to you so that you can
build amazing things yourselves Sam
we're big fans of gke and I'm super
excited for what's ahead I am too and
congratulations on everything you've
accomplished so far thank you CJ I don't
think it'll be a surprise to anyone in
this audience when I say that data is
critical to machine learning much like
how Google's Feifei Li created image net
sparked a frenzy of advancement in the
field our next startup is building a
massive data set of their own this time
that data set consists of millions of
microscopic images of human cells
armed with this data and Google Cloud
recursion Pharmaceuticals is on a
mission to redefine the drug discovery
process and bring life-saving drugs to
market faster please join me in
welcoming Lena Nielsen senior director
of data science at recursion
pharmaceuticals to tell us more
[Music]
we are decoding biology in order to find
new medical treatments I'm Lena Nelson
and I am incredibly excited to be here
today to share with you
recursions vision for the future of drug
discovery the number of new drugs
approved each year by the FDA has been
essentially stagnant since the 1980s and
the development cost of each of those
few drugs has increased tenfold to well
over two billion dollars contrast this
to the world of tech where costs are
coming down all the time and where the
smart phone in my pocket has more
compute that a 1980s supercomputer so
why has drug discovery not followed this
same pattern the traditional scientific
workflow is sequential researchers work
on one disease and one hypothesis at a
time this works but the rate of finding
new treatments is slow at recursion
we're transforming this old process into
a new formula where we test dozens or
even hundreds of diseases at once
instead of testing one hypothesis at a
time across that dataset we're able to
be open to millions of possible outcomes
in an unbiased way in this new formula
gives us the ability to dramatically
speed up the discovery of new drugs the
key to all of this is a combination of
one large-scale biology on our automated
robotics platform then to prediction and
inference on the cloud and finally
rigorous biology validation in the lab
to complete the drug discovery process
so let's stick in a bit and I'll show
you a bit more about how this all works
the first step is automated robotics
recursion has built an automated lab
full of robots that run about a hundred
thousand experiments every week this
gives us two million biology images to
work with every week by the end of this
year we'll be have the capability to
generate nearly 1 petabytes of image
data every month
this dwarves imagenet in these biology
images are then streamed to Google Cloud
and Iran through our data processing
platform which leverages Google
carbonaceous engine bigquery and of
course Google Cloud storage and this is
what those microscope images of human
cells look like each image you see shows
a different cell type exposed to
different diseases and of course
different potential treatments but
generating millions of images alone
that's not really going to help us reach
our ambitious goal it is only
transformative when we layer on machine
learning analytics on the cloud in order
to discover important patterns in the
data using preemptable virtual machines
for example our workloads can spike to
do all this image processing and deep
learning inference using tensorflow and
that allows us to iterate rapidly and to
develop new powerful machine learning
models in a really cost-effective way so
let me give you one really powerful
example of a model so here we built a
unified high dimensional representation
Laden space to help us identify the most
likely drugs to work for given disease
before we even run that test in the lab
so here I'm showing us a small subset of
this latent space data in a simplified
3d graphics so essentially taking
thousands of dimensions and turning that
into something that's visually
interpretable by humans
the red dots indicates the results of
adding decease to human cells in your
lab and the blue dots represent a
separate addition of drugs to cells in
the lab The Closer two dots are the more
similar their effects on human cells and
vice-versa so it turns out that drugs
tend to cluster on the opposite side of
the latent space from the drugs that
they work on so the works do drugs the
diseases that they can treat so what not
a perfect predictor this means that we
have a data pattern to help us identify
drugs that are likely to be effective or
to put it in another way this blue dot
diseases drugs you see here are likely
to be effective against the red dot
disease on the office
side this is really powerful because it
means that for the first time we do not
have to test every drug against every
disease in the laboratory we can predict
already on the cloud which drugs are
likely to work and this is a type of
approach that saves our scientists tons
of time and tons of resources and it's
also an example of the kind of
capability recursion is building out in
order to be able to exponentially
increase the efficiency in drug
discovery and that brings us to our
final step step 3 our team of biologists
validate and follow up on all of our
results robotics machine learning models
in human biologists then worked
hand-in-hand together to speed up all
the steps of the drug discovery pipeline
from in vitro to in vivo and then
eventually human medical trials in fact
using this new formula recursion already
has one drug cleared by the FDA for
human medical trials and we have a
pipeline of dozens of other drugs behind
it in just five short years this is a
tremendous volume not just for a small
startup like recursion but for any by a
pharma company we are in a journey to
decode biology and to find cures for
today's untreatable diseases I hope
you're inspired to join us thank you
[Music]
all right hey all right
was that a fun time or what yeah
so I want to recap you know our our
promise to you our commitment to you
the first is run innovation the second
is around openness and the third is
about being part of a community now I've
got something to announce that I want
you to pay attention to I'm incredibly
excited to announce that our community
is running dev fest community organized
developer events in five hundred cities
starting basically in a couple of weeks
so I hope you'll all find the local one
get plugged into that local community I
want to thank all of you thanks for your
participation thanks for your feedback
and your challenge now we're gonna do
something another that other thing I
want to tell you that we're gonna do now
is we're gonna officially announce a
save the date for the next next April
9th or 11th in San Francisco right here
[Music]